- Let's close out with something
we grabbed off social media
perfect for the holidays.
This is What I'm Liking.
(upbeat music)
(audience cheers and applauds)
Usually when you picture Santa
he's in his reindeer powdered sleigh,
lugging bundles of toys and
battling the winter weather.
You don't envision hundreds
of surfers dressed up as Santa
and his elves riding the waves
on Florida's East Coast. (chuckles)
But that happens every year
with thousands of onlookers
crowding the beach to watch.
We have the founder of this
giant event on the line.
Hi, George. This is so super cool.
(audience applauds)
So it started-
- Hey, Kelly.
- Small with your son, right?
- Yeah. I was born here
in the Cocoa Beach area
here on Florida's Space Coast.
And Cocoa Beach is known as the small wave
surfing capital of the world.
- Oh, wow.
- I'm close to 60 years old.
(audience applauding)
Back in 2009, my wife made me this
awesome surfing Santa outfit.
The newspaper took a picture
and published it and labeled
the picture Surfing Santa.
Over the years, the event has
grown and grown and grown.
It's unbelievable.
(audience applauding)
- Oh, that's so cool.
I love that, how that started
out and then it became this,
you created something so cool
and magical for so many people.
So, it's not just for fun though, right?
You're doing good as well, right?
- Yeah. On Christmas Eve,
we will have at least
400 people join us on
December 24th dressed to surf.
And our crowd, it'll exceed 10,000 people.
We have a costume contest.
There's live music.
We have Hawaiian dancers
that entertain us.
And everybody is smiling.
It's-
- That is so cool, man.
- Really, really fun.
(audience applauding)
- Your family created this
long-lasting tradition
that's probably gonna carry on, like,
for the next generation,
the next generation.
It's such a cool thing, George.
Thank you so much for starting
this and sharing this.
I'm liking your post right now, right?
(audience applauding)
(bell dings)
- Oh, thank you.
- Oh, absolutely.
And that's not all.
Our season-long partner,
Pilot Pen, makers of FriXion,
the go-to erasable pen of
the Kelly Clarkson Show
want to celebrate those creating
fearlessly just like you.
So they're gonna be writing you a check
for a thousand dollars to
the Florida Surf Museum.
How's that sound?
(audience cheers and applauds)
- Oh yeah! Thank you. That's great.
- Oh man, thank you so much
for joining us, George.
Have a good one.
And thank you to all our guests today.
Jewel, Andrea Savage, Jaylen, Julian,
Ron Peters, and Lawrence Zarian.
From my home to yours, have a great day,
and if it's not, well, try and change it.